Let me officially introduce you to Micah Wiens [oh] hello Ying
And he just ate a bunch of milk. So he is happily taking a nap
Micah!
mmm
Let's take a step back and jump back a couple of months to March
2016 and I had noticed that Ying was somehow eating a lot
Ying eats a lot normally but she was eating more than normal, an abnormal amount and I was so excited about it because
When we would go out to eat that means like we could order more food than we normally did
and we actually happened to be traveling in Jordan, and it was exactly the 27th of
March 2016 and that day we drove to the Dead sea
But somewhere along the day, I remember we stopped at a convenience store and
I wanted to buy some water and Ying wanted to buy some snacks and
Ying bought something in a box, and I didn't really even look at it
I didn't even know what it was
I didn't even think twice either because you can always buys like random lotions and cosmetics when we go into convenience stores
So I didn't even think of anything of it. I just paid and we took our bag we
Drove and continued on to the dead sea, and we checked into our hotel and right before
We went to dinner Ying comes out of the bathroom and she says Mark I
Think I'm pregnant. I remember Ying went back into the bathroom
she tested the second time just to confirm, came back with a positive result and
both of us were just
thrilled
Ying and I and our baby
Just finished taking a 39 day trip around the world we visited nine different cities
ten if you include Bangkok and just.
[It] Was the night before last night, we flew back from Hong Kong back to Bangkok and today. We have a doctor's [appointment] and
I am really excited to see the ultrasound. It has been about a month and a half since our last checkup and
So we are on our way to the hospital now
I always drink three or four waters
I don't think I mentioned this before, but we are having a boy and he is
800 grams already! The baby is healthy and Mama Ying is healthy.
It's September 29th, and it has only been 2 weeks since the last doctor's appointment checkup
That we've had but the doctor wanted us to come in again after two weeks because on our last checkup
The baby had not yet turned, and so everything was okay with the baby and the baby is healthy
He's healthy, but she wanted us the doctor wanted us to come back to make sure that he turns the last two weeks though
The baby has really really been squirming around in Ying's stomach you can you can actually just watch Ying's
stomach just bulge and go up and down. He is squirming around getting ready for the ultrasound. Check out that stomach
The baby has not yet turned, so the doctor said we should come back in three weeks, and hopefully he will have turned by then
34 weeks October 19 2016, Ying and I are in our new room
[haha], It's getting here! That sticks to your stomach
Since the last time I made a video we have moved into a new house, our previous house
It was going to get really crammed, and we wanted to our baby to have his own room
I'm going to set up the baby bed right now
I think I better quickly look at the instructions to see how to put this together
I managed to work up quite a sweat putting that together feels pretty sturdy. We just finished with the doctor's appointment and
Unfortunately he still hasn't turned so he's still in the breech position with his head up and his feet down
So that's a little bit concerning
And today we have another checkup
and we've definitely made some progress and some big things have changed, the first thing that I want to share with you is that
well first of all, I am
Pretty bad with names and I never really I never even really thought
You know some people how they like love certain names, and how they've been dreaming about
Naming someone a certain name that they love I have never ever had any of those thoughts
So we finally came across Micah and what we're thinking is that his first name will be English
And then his middle name will be Thai
And then his last name of course will be Wiens and then the second big thing that has changed
Since the last vlog about the baby two weeks ago. We're gonna have to go outside, but I'm really excited for this one
It has been over 10 years since the last car that I owned which is back in the U.S. during university
And then I sold off everything to travel and I came to Thailand in Southeast, Asia
That's where I met Ying and life changed
And so this is the first car that I've owned since university which has been maybe
Yeah, exactly exactly
nine, nine, ten years ago
One of the biggest reasons we got this car is because I did not want Ying
or the baby to be riding around in Bangkok Taxis, and it's just not safe to ride motorbikes and
And when thinking about having a baby, transportation
becomes a challenge and so the real best way to get around is by having your own car transportation in Bangkok and
Also with this vehicle I'm really hoping to get off the beaten path in thailand, so that's hopefully what you can expect in the future
lots of Road tripping in thailand to come
There's his face
And his nose. The doctor said he has some of my same features
He's pretty tall and quite thin as well kind of like, kind of like me, and then we saw his face
It's amazing the only
Difficulty now is that he still hasn't turned so he's still in the breech position, so this is
starting to get a little bit concerning and the doctor has
Recommended that we might have to schedule for a c-section
Good morning, everyone it is November 12th
2016 and
Ying woke up this morning
And she said that the baby wasn't really moving like he normally does and she also said that she has a headache
So she decided to call the hospital to see if we could book an appointment
And we were hopefully just going to have a quick ultrasound make sure the baby is okay
We arrived to the hospital, and then they brought us up to the birth unit
division, and they brought us into a room, checked the heartbeat of the baby is all okay
And then the doctor came in and took a look at Ying and she said Ying has gone into labor.
Surprise!
So she said today we need to do an emergency C-section
And by the way when you come into the birth unit you take off your shoes, and they give you some pink Crocs
Getting ready to go into the operating room
All right, let's do this
Oh, for my ears
All right, I am ready
That was one of the scariest, but the absolute happiest and most
Joyous moment of my entire life
His name is Micah and he is hanging out right there
Mama Ying has just been rolled into the room
She is a
champion! It's about 6:00 p.m. this evening in Bangkok. It has been a long day and a surprising
kind of shocking, but the most amazing
Joyous day that I've ever had in my life
I cannot even explain the feeling I had when I was sitting with Ying in the operating room and
moments, and then somewhere during that
During that situation. I could all of a sudden hear a baby crying and I got my first glimpse of Micah and
then holding him for the first time and
Also a big thank you to the doctors and all the nurses that helped
They I'm so glad they know what they're doing, and also I just praise God for Micah being healthy. He's healthy. He's strong
Ying had, even though we would have preferred to give a natural birth if possible
it worked out for the c-section, and that's what the safest way and
The way the doctor recommended so and even we weren't expecting at all to have a baby today
God always has a plan. I am so happy right now, and I cannot even express my
My joy
but
Yeah, it's, it's amazing. It's an amazing feeling
Hi cutie, you smiling? Yeah. Yeah, he's smiling.
My name is Ying and he is your daddy. You can see him even when he's asleep, he is practicing his eating
He's going to be an eater
I've never been
happier and prouder
in my life, and I can just like
I could just sit here and like look at him all the time
Yeah, it's just the most amazing
sensational experience
That I wouldn't trade for anything
[Captioning provided by Jorge Rizo]